[музика]
Добрий
день
Тримай
[музика]
наяву Хай
цю
бу останній раз
так
Я
знаю
іля
заршення
колись то
було були
розкож після кожного
засідання
правильнока інтелектуаль пра
вимагаєповнення
кабіне
[музика]
ва
поряд
проек ц
ю тепер такий те
задто
багатося за
пози
їттре
ро
зна
добрий
Доброго дня вельми Шановні колеги
Доброго дня учасники засідання
атестаційної
колегії У нас сьогодні доволі напружений
порядок денний
19 позицій в цьому порядку денному у нас
зараз є кворум атестаційної колегії е
Шановні колеги ви бачите порядок денний
У вас є якісь пропозиції по зміні
порядку денного доповнення якихось
питань нічого немає так
тоді приступаємо до розгляду питань
перше питання стратегія розв'язання
проблем наукової доброчесності Шановні
колеги я поставила це питання з такою
метою щоб ми не тільки розглядали
поточні питання А вибудовували тактику
як відбуває як як в цілому буде
вирішуватися проблеми академічної
доброчесності Як вам ві і домо в нас
прийнятий закон про вищу освіту новий
але при імплементації цього закону на
даний момент в нас утворилася серйозна
прогалина це питання забезпечення якості
вищої освіти і в тому питання
академічної
доброчесності тому що опікуватися цим
повинен орган Національне агентство
забезпечення якості вищої
освіти на превеликий жаль це агентство
мало запрацювати ще з 1 вересня минулого
року але воно не було робота його не
була
запущена зараз ми зробили всі кроки для
того щоб агентство почало як найшвидше
працювати І я просила вам надати проект
плану запуску агентства надано матеріали
чому будь
ласка Володимирович прошу доповісти про
стан запуску але я хотіла щоб
ознайомилися з планом
роботи попередньо було розроблено для
запуску національне агенства з питань
забезпечення якості вищої освіти
міністерством освіти був запропоновано
свій план детальний запис а водночас
Міністерство освіти воно не впливає
безпосередньо на роботу самого назяу
тому була створена робоча група з
представників назял в основному до якого
долучено кілька представників від
міністер ства зокрема заступник Міністра
греба Роман пан Шевцов долучений пан
шарок долучений для того щоб надати
методологічну допомогу самого процесу
учасники робочої групи
А мають свій трошки відозмірний погляд
на порядок запуску агентства водночас
Він багато в чому співпадає різницю він
тільки в деяких деталях тому вони взя
перше засідання робочої групи ми провели
На минулому тижні в п'ятницю і на
наступному тижні буде вже детальний план
повністю затвердженя крім того
Міністерство свого боку запустило на
погодження до центральних органів
виконавчої влади зміни до статуту
національного агентства з питань
забезпечення вищої якості освіти для
того щоб можна було повноцінно запустити
од одною і перетон зокрема на шлядх до
запуску назяву є відсутність особи
уповноваженя на реєстрацію так бу
документи з нормативно-правомі
підготовлення раніше що не було
визначена особа яка вдає за реєстрацію
самої юридичної особи назяв зараз ця
недоречність усунута і після прийняття
нової редакції статуту у нас не буде
перешкод для того щоб зареєструвати саме
назяву після цього відбудеться
затвердження Кабміном уже відповідно до
того закону який був прийнятий нещодавно
Верховною Радою і маємо сподівання що
невдовзі буде підписаний Президентом
України відповідно до цього закону склад
начаву затверджується постановою Кабміну
Ми сподіваємося що найближчим часом такі
буде зроб
тому в принципі Ми йдемо дуже активно
рухаємося на шляху до запуску назяву Я
маю сподівання що максимум у вересні
місяці
ця агенція розпочне свою роботу е Дякую
зрозуміло це надзвичайно важливо тому що
насправді закон про вищу освіту не діє
комплексносистемно коли в нас немає
такої незалежної інституції бо за її
роботою криється е нові редакції великої
кількості документів і зокрема тих які
стосуються саме академічної
доброчесності тому що відповідно до
закону е саме в рамках національного
агентства забезпечення якості вищої
освіти утворюється Комітет з питань
етики і апеляційний комітет і саме
Комітет з питань етики розглядає питання
академічного плагіату і вносить
відповідні подання до самого
національного агентства в той же час
апеляційний комітет теж розглядає
звернення заяви і скарги щодо діяльності
та рішень спеціалізованих вчених рад і
вносить відповідні подання до
Національного агентства
ее на даний момент ми користуємося
фактично в таких випадках е законом
України про авторське право і суміжні
права і можна звичайно оскаржувати
рішення спеціалізованих вчених рад і
порушення цих прав у судах а також
керуємося чинною постановою яка на даний
момент е є для нас підставою наших дій
це порядок присудження наукових ступенів
і присвоєння вченого звання старшого
наукового
співробітника тому я вважаю що для того
щоб ми в стратегічній перспективі могли
говорити про всі речі які Ми зараз
робимо Шановні колеги А я хочу
повідомити що спільно з посольством
Сполучених Штатів Америки в нас
реалізується проект академічної
доброчесності в рамках якого
визначається е певні напрямки роботи з
академічними спільнотами щодо цього але
також є ще один проект створення
національного репозитарію академічних
текстів і на базі цього е репозитарію
буде здійснювати здійснюватися якраз
антиплагіатна перевірка тому що сьогодні
ця антиплагіатна перевірка теж залежить
від того хто її здійснює і якими
об'ємами текстів він при цьому керується
е перш за все все це поставити потрібно
на стійку нормативно-правову нову основу
в яку буде включено Національне
агентство забезпечення якості вищої
освіти і якщо Е чому я доповідає це саме
на засіданні е атестаційної колегії бо
це для нас питання яке Ми
повинні теж з боку колегії контролювати
і
підтримувати тому що нам буде значно
легше працювати якщо буде відповідна
нормативно-правова правова база якщо ви
маєте члени атестаційної колегії щось
сказати на тему Власне стратегічного
розв'язання цієї проблеми що ми ще
можемо зробити будь ласка запрошую якщо
ні то прошу прийняти цю інформацію до
відима бо до вас теж можуть ставитися
питання А що з назябо чи буде воно
запускатися що з новою
нормативно-правовою базою Я вважаю що
члени колегії повинні бути
поінформовані будь ласка Якщо хтось хоче
засловитися
прошу е ви сказали про Національний
репозитарій це дуже важливо оскільки
програмне забезпечення антиплагіату
зараз вже майже вирішено ну достатньо
нормально але з чим порівнювати у
откритому інтернеті ясно укрнкі Не дає
не відкриває тести укрнти і треба його
зобов'язати щоб воно оцей репозитарій
передало всі від цифрованя дисертації
минулих років якщо цього не буде ми
будемо наштовкуватись е ну на на
неприємності оскільки потім з'ясовується
що що 10 років тому закіалась дисертація
і там плагіат і буде відповідати
ее там голова ради І так далі Тому треба
це якось обов'язково про нормативно
прописати прошу до протоколу нести
протоколу рекомендації ще будь ласка
прошу пане міністр є та аналогічна
проблема є із питаннями закритих робіт
те що у нас є от національному
університеті оборону ми це можемо робити
але цілий ряд робіт іде поза межами е
університету тому мабуть ее ми будемо її
пропонувати так щоби всі роботи десь
акумулювати ну мабуть і в національному
університеті оборони де ми зможемо
здійснювати таку перевірку і що стосовно
закритих робіт це також треба робити щоб
нас не ніхто не провав за цим за межами
таємни закритості тобто спеціальний
репозитарій до якого ті мають допуск хто
має допуск Так хто працює закритими
роботами закритими математикамилі в нас
управління ціле університеті відповідно
зрозуміло добре беремо це
як ще будь
ласка так добре добре дякую Шановні
колеги зараз ми переходимо до другого
питання скасування рішень
спеціалізованих вчених рад прошу
подивитись на додаток
одиндиви
подивилися так доповідає Андрій гаріович
цов Отже колеги
стснко Володимир
Іванович захистив дисертацію по історії
України спеціальність
072001яс в Хмельницькому державному
педогічному університеті імені Григорія
свароди голова спеціальної ради
Гончаренко Олексій
миколайовичценко во прац працює працював
на той час методистом
навчально-методичній лабораторії цього ж
університету 10 березня 16го року до
Міністерства освіти і науки надійшло
звернення від доктора історичних наук
завідуючаого кафедри світової історії
нового і новітнього часу Український
Католицький Університет Вадима ададурова
щодо наявності текстових запозичень у
дисертації спиценка Володимира Івановича
на тему внесок українського народу в
перемогу у Вітчизняній війні 1812 року
здобтя наукогоступеня кандидата
річч захист дисертації відбувся 26
лютого 16го року у спеціалізований чені
раді ряснохліцького державного дичного
університету ви можете досттковувати
інформацію на слайдах дещо вивели на
екран так що можна це дивитися з текст
добре
добре атестаційна справа атестаційна
справа спеценка надійшла до Міністерства
30 березня 16го року атестаційну справу
дисертацію та матеріали щодо наявності
текстових запози дисертації стаценка
було винесено на розгляд експертної Ради
з питань проведення експертизи
дисертації мов з історичних наук 11 11
квітня 16го року із запрошенням
здобувача висновок експертної рани за
результатами розгляду дисертації
спеценко пропонуватимо надіслати
дисертацію на додаткове колективне
рецензування до спеціалізованої вченої
ради Харківського національного
університету імені Каразіна та Одеського
національного університету імені
Мечникова крім того
Слід зазначити що 6 червня 16го року до
Міністерства освіти надійшов висновок
науково-дослідного центру судової
експертизи з питань інтелектуальної
власності Міністерства осві Міністерства
юстиції
України цей висновок ви можете титулку
побачити і слід Слід зазначити що цей
висновок був зроблено на замовлення саме
католицького українського католицького
університету
отже з результатами проведеного
експертного дослідження у сфері
інтелектуної власності від 20 травня
16-го року в якому зазначено наявність
значної кількості текстуальних збігів у
фрагментах тексту дисертації стиценка та
нографії ададурова збігів у
послідовності викладу наукових понять та
розміщення матеріалу тощо
А є статистика
84 560 знаків або 2,1 авторських аркуша
або приблизно 46 сторінок стандартного
дисертиційного тексту тобто текстове
запозиченні склали
23%. прошу звернути увагу на цю
і це свідчить про те що при створенні
дисертації стаценка було частково
витворено текст монографії Вадима
ададурова У дисертації на здобаття
наукого ступеня кандидата історичних
наук у зв'язку з надходженням додаткових
матеріалів повторно розглянута
експертною радою це питання на засіданні
члени ради були ознайомлені зі змістом
нових матеріалів щодо наявності
текстових запозичень без посилання на
джерело дисертаційні роботи висновок
експертної Ради за результатами розгляду
атестаційної справи дисертації спеценка
та виявня порушення порядку присудження
наукових ступенів затвердженого
постанови Кабміну 13го року в номері 567
частини вимог пункту дев'ятого щодо
особистого виконання здобувачем
дисертації на здобвня наукового ступеня
пункту 10 стосовно наявності дисертації
наукових положень та науково
обґрунтованих результатів щодо яких
здобувач є суб'єктом авторського права
пункту 14-го щодо зазначення в
дисертації та в авторефераті конкретного
особистого
внеску якщо У дисертації використані
ідеї або розробки що належать
співавторам з суттєвою обставиною в
оцінки самостійності дослідження
пропонувати мож відхилити рішення
спеціалізованої вченої ради про
присудження наукового ступеня кандидата
історичних наук центу Володимиру
івановичу звернути увагу наукового
керівника офіційних компонентів та
членів експертної ради спеціалізованої
вчено ради експер комісії вибачаюсь
спеціалізованої вченої ради на
неприпустимість наявності текстових
запозичень без посилання на джерело
удисертаційних роботах результати
голосування 17 за проти немає отрималось
Немає Отже наш висновок Який ми
пропонуємо шановним членам атестаційної
колег перше скасувати рішення
спеціалізованої вченої ради переяслу
Хмельницького державного едогічного
університету від 26 лютого 16го року
протокол номер три про присудження
наукового ступеня кандидата історичних
наук стаценко Володимиру івановичу друге
вказати науковому керівникові доктору
історичних наук професору борисенку
офаційним опонентом доктору наук
професору рієнту кандидату історичних
наук доценту скритнику експертній
комісії доктору історичних наук
професору орлику доктору історичних наук
старшому нако співробітнику любовець
доктору історичних наук професору
молоткині На
неприпустимість порушення нормативних
актів у сфері атестації кадрів вищої
кваліфікації
Шановні колеги Хто має
запитання У мене є тоді У мене є
запитання у нас закон про вищу освіту
передбачає що якщо спеціалізована вчена
рада так пропускає таку роботу то в
цьому випадку повинні бути певні санкції
на певний час призупинення діяльності
деяких членів ченої рад які давали
позитивні висновки
експертна рада вважає що поки мож
обмежити з
попередження так експертна комісія Я так
розумію це єсть експертна комісія ішле в
Раду експертна рада спецілі то експертна
комісія спеціалізована вченої рада Та що
допустила ну оця експертна комісія
вченої ради до Я так розумію опоненти
само собою науковий керівник само собою
і так так
так так так такщо заходи проти вченої
ради прийняті абсолютно я
на перший на перший крок Ну я хочу
повідомити що ця рада наразі припинила
свою діяльність нема А ця Рада припинила
сго треба і
починати Отже ця Рада припинила
діяльність заперечень немає проти
скасування
рішення позбавлення відповідно не
позбавлення тому що він ще не
присуджений це рішення тільки спецради
про присння наукового вступлення
Стеценко Володимиру івановичу Хто за
запропоноване і зачитане Андрієм
гаровичем рішення прошу
голосувати хто
проти
утримався Дякую наступна справа будь
ласка спеціальність державного
управління Денисюк Олександр Васильович
1973 року народження спеціальність
252002 механізми державного управління
е Олександр Васильович працює
начальником фінансового відділу
управління служби безпеки України в
Харківській області я наголошу на прошу
звернути увагу чно колеги Що він не є
співробітником вищї школи тому Ми
змушені були за процедурую пропустити
обов'язково через експертну Раду цю
е цю роботу
відповідно до пункту першого пункту
восьмого положення про експертну Раду
атестаційну справу та дисертацію
денісюка розглянуто е радою 11 квітня
16го року у присутності
здобувача будласка
слай висновок експертної ради висновок
експертної ради достатньо достатньо
великий ви можете тут побачити деякі
слайди де буде описано в чому власне є
зауваження х наради і заперечення щодо
посудження
ступиня з вашого дозволу я скорочу
скорочу цю частину то хоче може
ознайомитись з матеріалами справи але я
зразу почитаю Які зауваження до змісту
дисертації були е зроблені експертною
радою перше дисертаційне дослідження
здійснено на низькому теоретичному рівні
більшість його положень є дискусійними і
хибними що пов'язана з відсутністю
наукового підходу до досліджуваної
проблеми
відсутність наукового апарату викладення
матеріалу дослідження використання
ненаукових конструкцій примітивність
побутови аналізу наукової проблеми
використання наукової термінології є
нехарактерним для науки державного
управління досить часто у тексті
зустрічаються російськомовні конструкції
що почасти свідчить про використання
російськомовних електронних ресурсів
логіка дослідження при цьому не
послідковується автор поєднує приватний
та публічний сектор регулювання і на ці
основі у роботі побудо ненаукові
твердження при цьому домінують посилання
автора на навчальні посібники та
поблікачї загального характеру що не
мають про дисертації прямого відношення
друге до системних проблем дослідження
слід віднести відсутність узагальнення
методології дослідження при цьому
наприклад виділяючи на сторінці 19й
певні групи дослідників Автор вказує
виключно зарубіжних вчених виділяє три
підходи до проблеми проте наводить лише
два підходи так само матеріали хаотично
подані у другому третьому розділу при
цьому невідомо де закінчується цитування
А де починається власна
думка тому що при аналізі тексто на
програмах виявлення плагіат з'ясовано що
у багатьох випадках цитування подано з
посиланням проце частина цитування
продовжена автором як власна думка Разом
з тим національні школи подані у
дослідження поверхова а відповідні
розробки науковців галузі державного
управління праактично відсутні у списку
використаних джерел та у тексті
дисертації домінує проблематика
регіонального розвитку регіональної
політики лістики хоча предметом та
завданням такі є напрямки дослідження
вони необумовлені мова йде про
виключення про включення до тексту
дисертації певних обсягів тексту для
збільшення обсягу роботи і джерел у
роботі практично по всьому тексту
спостерігається порушення вимог щодо
оформлення наявні чи численні рисунки що
автор дисертації подає виконання
самостійно четверте недотримання вимог
паспорту наукової спеціальності
механізми державного управління за
назвою дота ція віднесена до
спеціальності механізму державного
управління проте за змістом структурою
метою та завданням не відповідає
паспорту формули спеціальност у
завданнях Та візні так само як і
висновках зв'язку тексту дисертації не
спостерігається положення паспорту
спеціальноністі в результатах
дослідження не вдображені дане
дисертаційне дослідження має змістовний
економічний акцент виконани в межах
економічної науки при цьому часткове
використання державної управлінської
термінології не впливає на характер
роботи П'яте всі лікації автора виконані
в 15му році у тому числі у електронних
виданнях та видані з іноземною назвою
перевірка наведених публікацій
засвідчила включення таких матеріалів до
тексту дисертації проте рівень виконання
публікацій невисокий існують Повтори
змістовного плану крім того
відповідно дві довідки про впровадження
результатів дисертації нашли надійшли у
липні 15го року при цьому у статті у
фактових виданнях почали друкуватися
саме в цей час шо просто при аналізі
тексту виявлено що хоча й робота
підготовлена в 15-му році більшість
джерел надрукована до 2009 року а 30% до
2003 року при цьому видання 10-15 років
без праць автора складають 15% 15
одиниць 7%. при вказані джерел
спостерігається використання електронних
ресурсів при цьому перевірка програмами
виявлення плагіату показала наявність
посилань на електронні ресурси виконання
студентських робіт при цьому автор
вільно подає точку зору науковців без
цитування вказаних призві взагалі за
загалом характеристики механізму у
роботі не наведено практично мова може
йти про відсутність наукової цінності
роботи так останнє осталось сім пунктів
що висновки носять характер
скомпільованих узагальнень і восьме всі
зазначені недоліки мали б мали бути
зазначені офіційними опонентами проте у
віруках наведені другорядні зауваження
отак отже загальний висновок переоцінки
дисертації аналіз тексту роботи вказує
що подані в дисертації результати
досліджень неактуальні не мають
теоретичної практичної цінності робота
виконана на низькому науковому рівні е
дисертаційну роботу не можна вважати
завершеним самостійним науковому
дослідження в якому розв'язано важливе
наукове завдання в галузі науки
державного управління висновок
експертної ради дисертаційна робота не
відповідає вимогам пункту 11го порядку
присудження наукових ступенів пропозиція
експертної ради скасувати шення
спеціалізованої вченої ради
національного університету цивільного
захисту України Про присудження
наукового ступеня ката наук державного
управління Денисенко Олександру
Васильовичу та відмовити у видачі
диплома кандидата наук державного
управління за спеціальністю механізмі
державного
управління колеги які є пропозиції
пропозиція одна
дозвоте
підтримати рішення експертної ради тому
що ви подивіться навіть що таке
економічна без безпека фінансового
сектору я що первинне що
вторинний в нього фінансовий сектор
получається вищей чим чим економічна
безпека хоча на самому ділі Це абсолютно
навпаки все фінанси - це частинка
маленька частинка економічної безпеки у
нього це навпаки зразу тому уже сама оця
постановка питання говорить про те що це
воно прис от А скоро так То про що можна
говорити підтримати
однознач так щодо членів спецради тут
немає ніяких санкцій бо вона припинила
свою діяльністі цієї ради немає так я і
в попередньому випадку Таким чином
Шановні колеги на голосування виноситься
е наша пропозиція скасувати рішення
спеціалізованої ченої ради національного
університету цивільного захисту про
присудження наукового ступеня кандидата
наук з державного управління денисюку
Олександру Васильовичу і відмовити у
видачі диплома кандидата НАУ в
державного управління Хто за таке
рішення прошу
голосувати хто проти
утримався одноголос
Дякую Так наступне питання це питання
щодо позбавлення наукового ступеня
кандидата наук
Філіпова Валерія леонідови прошу
арійви Філіпов Валерій Леонідович
захищався по спеціальності 1305
соціальна
педагогіка 13го жовтня 2004 року йому
було посудження науково ступані
кандидата політичних наук згідно
постанови Вак від цієї
дати він на той час працював ректором
луганського державного інституту
культури і
містецьв в місті Луганську на цей час як
нам відомо він продовжує очолювати цей
цей університет і інститут культури і
здійснює свою діяльність на окупованій
території заклад залишився там Працювати
він його
очолює тепер по змісту по змісту роботи
11 листопада 15-го року до Міністерства
надійшло звернення доктора педичних наук
професора Караман директора інституту
педагогіки психології державного закладу
Луганський національний універсиітет
імені Шевченка місто Старобільськ з
інформацією щодо наявності текстових
запозичень без посилання на джерело У
дисертації філіппова дисертація була на
тему організації педагічної взаємодії з
підлітками студентів коледжу як
оптимальну умова їх соціального
встановлення з мето з метою перевіки
фактів наведених у зверненні
Міністерство надіслало матеріали
звернення до спеціалізованої вченої ради
інституту проблем
виховання Академії диічних Наук для
надання висновку щодо підтвердження або
спростування факту наявності текстових
запозичень без посилання на джерело
дисертації
філіппова експертна комісія у складі
доктора подичних наук професора петрочку
доктора подичних наук професора
Кравченко та доктора подичних наук
професора
Федорченко призначені спеціалізованої
вченою радою інституту проблем виховання
зробили певні висновки на слайді ви
можете побачити
певні цифри конкретні сторінки де було
знайдено текстові
запозичення Таким чином на підставі
вивчення представлених матеріалів
дисертації
Філіпова експертна комісія підтверджує
наявні факти текстових за запозичень без
посилання на відповідні джерела в тому
числі на дисертацію Карпенко соціальне
встановлення особистості підлітка в
тимчасових об'єднаннях за інтересами на
на здобуття наукового ступеня кабната
подлічих наук а та дисертації кірічука
на тему психолого-педагічні умови
стимулювання соціальної комунікативної
активності
старшокласників
і треба Слід зазначити що ця дисертація
захищалася в спеціальній поічній раді
національногодично вченої раді
національного подичного університету
імені Драгоманова і на час розгляду цієї
апеляції цієї скарги ця спеціальна Рада
припинила свою діяльність тобто ми не
могли звернутися до цієї самої ради тому
що її просто не було Тому відповідно до
пункту
третього до третього пункту пер статті
порядку просудження наукових
ступенів Міністерство доручило
спеціалізованой вчено раді Київського
університету імені Бориса Грінченка
розглянути інформацію заємника Караман і
надало висновок інституту проблеми
виховання Національної академії під наук
розгляд відбувся на засіданні
спеціалізованої навчальної ради
Київському університеті імені гріченка
21 червня 16го
року на засіданні виступили доктор
новуплахтіону яка проінформувала
присутніх що в 10му році як експер
експертвакт за спеціальності
спеціального довики вона була членом
групи щодо перевірки наукової
достовірності роботи Філіпова і комісія
уже тоді зазначила низький науковий
рівень дисертації наявних текстових
запозичень і рекомендувала позбавити
автора звання кандидата дичних наук
проте тодішні керівництва Вак України не
прийняло відповідних рішень щодо
Філіпова доктор медичних наук вайнола
зазначила що раді представлені лише
ксрокопії співпадань текстів з обох
дисертацій оскільки це повторний позов
про скасування роботи з метою повної
об'єктивності доцільно було б розробити
перевірку за системою
антипгія доктор подичк наук чернуха
засвідчила що вона працювала з Караман і
запевнела присутнік у її Науковій
об'єктивності тому воно повністю
підлягає повністю підлягає позицію
карман і просять підтримує
ма і просять підтримати пропозицію про
позбавлення наукового ступеня Філіпова
Ну і є інші свдчення Отже було прийнято
рішення порушити клопотання перед
міністерством освіти і науки України про
позбавлення Філіпова наукового ступеня
кандидата подвчих наук і спеціальност
13005 спеціальна педагогіки результати
голосування за 11 проти немає утрималось
один
чи є
запитання немає Немає Отже Шановні
колеги Хто за те щоб підтримати
рішення
по позбавленню наукового ступеня
кандидата наук Філіпова Валерія
леонідовича прошу
голосувати хто проти
утримався
Дякую
Так наступне Шановні колеги ми також
маємо звернення ви знаєте що
це справа Яка теж набуває певного
розголосу і ми тому її поставили ще раз
на засідання атестаційної колегії це
розгляд висновку спеціалізованої вченої
ради національного університету
біоресурсів природокористування щодо
дисертації Катерини Михайлівни Кириленко
до нас до Міністерства освіти і науки
знову надходять
звернення доктора філософських наук
професора завідувача кафедрою
культурології Київського національного
університету культури і мистецтв пані
паркоменко е у
е виявлення фактів виявлення текст
текстових
запозичень
і як відомо за рішенням атестаційної
колегії Міністерства освіти і науки від
25 лютого цього року
дисертацію доктора педагогічних наук
Катерини Кириленко надіслано до
спеціалізованої вченої ради Харківського
національного педагогічного університету
і
ее ця спеціалізована вчена рада у своєму
висновку не
підтвердила фактів наведених заявницею і
в нас цей висновок є докладений у вас ми
цей висновок надіслали відповідно до
нормативно-правових актів якими ми
керуємося про які я вам говорила у
доповіді першого витання е до
спеціалізованої вченої ради в якій
захищалася Катерина Кириленко
і відбулося власне засідання цієї
спеціалізованої вченої ради ми зараз
маємо висновок спеціалізованої вченої
ради засідання якої відбулося 10 червня
2016 року у присутності як заявників які
оскаржували певні порушення так само і
Катерини
Кириленко сьогодні перед вами у ваших
матеріалах також є висновок
спеціалізованої вченої ради який надала
ця спеціалізована вчена рада з приводу
текстових запозичень ви щойно чули ми
мали три випадки
е-е скасування рішень спеціалізованих
вчених рад і серед них був один випадок
позбавлення наукового ступення ви чули
За які порушення це було зроблено і які
текстові запозичення в масштабах
однієї/третьї дисертаційних досліджень
були використані при цьому плюс ціла
низка інших порушень про які ми говорили
е Давайте ми зараз
все-таки ще раз обговоримо
ее питання висновків цих спеціалізованих
вчених рад можна буде
е поставити питання також до пані
Катерини Кириленко плюс сьогодні всі
мали доступ до цього засідання всі хто
хотіли могли на них на нього прийти і
теж поставити свої питання плюс ми
забезпечили трансляцію засідання для
того щоб Ті хто хочуть знати правду
могли її почути раз і по-друге порівняти
з тими роботами і з тими ситуаціями коли
дійсно таке позбавлення наша атестаційна
колегія в межах чинного законодавства
здійснює Я хочу запросити до слова
голову спеціалізованої вченої ради
станіславом Миколайовичем
ніколаєм
а шановні Юлія Михайлівна Шановні колеги
дійсно в липні
2015 26 червня 2015 року до нашої
спеціалізованої ради
260418 поступило заява зверненнятерини
Михайлівни по надала нам матеріали
дисертацію з проханням провести захист
прилюд
цієї дисертації 10 липня 15-го року наша
е було було засідання де ми підготували
[музика]
повністю комісію експертну в складі
професоірів докторів нановумедичних
озерах ручив прогодія який відповідно до
пункту 31 положення про спеціалізовану
чейну раду
підготували висновок про науковий рівень
дисертації 16 липня Минулого року також
в відповідності з
положенням Ми надіслали повідомлення про
захист дисертації до офіційного висновку
Міністерства освіти газети освіту
України яка й була опублікована
відповідно з нашим поданням в серпні
15го року 14 вересня 15го року були
розіслені всі документи а реферат і так
далі І так далі за 30 календар рних днів
до захисту зазначе дати зазначення
автоферат дисертації було розміщено
автореферат а за 10 календарних днів
рецензії відгуки офіційних
пропоня 15 жовтня публічно в присутності
великої кількості бажаючих
спеціалізованій начельні Раді В нашому
університеті було захищено дисертацію на
здобуття на по ступеню кандидата доктора
едагічних наук по спеціальності теорії
методика професійної освіти Катериною
керолеко
е за проголосувало із 14 членів
спеціалізованої ради таємно 14 зда з них
було шість докторів наук за профілом
дисертації після цього ще протягом трьох
місяців як цього вимагає інструкція всі
необхідні матеріали були розміщені на
сайті для публічного ознайомлення всіх
бажаю Протягом цього періоду воду до
спеціалізованої вчельної ради не
надійшло жодного
зауваження крім скажімо тих дискусії
робочої яка велась на захисті експертів
при роботі експертів і так далі І так
далі тому ми і керуючись положенням
пунктом 48 про спеціалізовану вчену
радую та пунктом 24 порядку присудження
ступенів надіслали адміністратор єдино
державної електронної бази електронні
приміни всі документи те що вимагає
інструкції Ну як же сказали відбулося
засідання вишї конституційної комісії і
15 грудня 15го року Кириленко
був присвоє вірніше виданий диплом
доктора педогічних
наук в травні місяці цього року Ну
звичайно ми знайомилися з усіма
публікаціями які були в пресі кожну
публікацію Ми ретельно розглядали мало
того я вам скажу ми запрошували до себе
скажімокатерину михайлівну Кириленко і і
скажімо ці експерти ми питали в неї і
аналізували самі об'єктивно що ж
відбувається Але мені здається що в
даному випадку вищаційна комісія
Міністерства зробила правильно коли
направили всі документи сумнів які були
до Харківського національного гічного
університету де На нашу думку зібралися
дійсно фахівці даної галуз і наскільки
мені відомо з тих висновків які ми
отримали а вони там голосували в
таємному режимі наскільки мені відомо і
17 осіб 16 проголосувало і підтвердили
повністю наший Висновок про те що прац
Кириленко є закінчена наукова праця А що
стосується скажімо всіх Там зауважень
які з'явилися і з'являються останнім
часом то там проведений був ретельний
аналіз я от наприклад протягом двох днів
ще раз додатково це все вивчав разом з
своїми колегами хочу сказати що дійсно
проведена величезна робота і ось нам 11
травня цього року надходеть лист від
Міністерства освіти і науки за підписом
першого заступника міністра сосум іни
яка просить нас просить нас розглянути
звернення заявників патоменко інших а
також висновки Харківської
спеціалізованої ради тобто тут не стоїть
питання про захист перезахист
розгляти ми збираємо публічне засідання
спеціалізованої ченої ради запрошую всіх
учасників були колеги які взяли дискусію
участь у дискусії хочу сказати що я
найменш зацікавлений і всі Мої колеги в
тому щоб ми десь там щось викривили
когось обманули якусь нечесність скажімо
підтримували
і коли скажімо був ми знову створили
комісію із трьох найбільш таких
підготовлених по ці спеціальності людей
які скажімо разом з харків'янами ще раз
і ще раз подивилися всі ці зауваженя
вони прийшли до висновку що дійсно
дисертації десь в межах оно 1,4% в
теоретичній частині єсть певні
конструкції слів там фраз
загальнотеоретично вживаного рівня вони
ви не вважають їх що це є тотожні і не
вважають що це є список і таке інше тому
на засіданні спеціалізованої ради всі 14
присутніх
ее членів спеціалізованої ради докторів
наук проголосува
ми Висновок затвердили про те
що дана робота відповідає вимогам Вам
тут в цьому висновку ві вас в роздано є
сім пунктів зокрема ми вважаємо що
основні наукові результати дисертації
Кириленко теоретичні методичні основи
формування наційної культури майбутні
культурологів отримані автором
самостійно що підверджується
запровадженням низкою праць і таке інше
е дискусія яка ведеться в пресі звичайно
вона ведеться тому кому як хочеться про
це писати Справа в тому що скажімо
дискутується ті чи інші підручники
посібники Ну наприклад кажуть що не
вистачає там якихось праць ну люди
абсолютно некомпетентні тому що сьогодні
скажімо інструкція дозволяє наявність
одного посібника скажімо по педагогічним
роботам вважати що це є наукова праця
або скажімо стверджується що
загальновідомі слова якісь вираз и там
Ну наприклад Україна впевнено
інтегрується в освітній європейський
освітній простір ну це не може бути
запозичення бо це загально вживані слова
я не буду в цю тему входити тому що
експерти зробили і поняна таблиця по
кожному зауважею коли ми з цим протягом
д по годин ознайомилися то ми затвердили
цей висновок направили його до комісії
до Міністерства освіти і науки і взяли
до відома що статистична перевірка
тексту дисертації наведених статей
говорить про те що таких підстав для
позбавлення скажем дисертації автора
немає окрім того ми я вам скажу про це
не було ніде ми вимагаємо вже майже рік
щоби нам давали обов'язково і висновки
Вони тільки народжуються в спеціальних
скажімо організацій на наявність чи
відсутність плагіату Кириленко перед
захистом представила таі виски інших
матеріалів у нас які б скажімо ее е
говорили нам про те що незаконні статті
є вони не відповідають скажімо вимогам
положень постанови Кабінету Міністрів в
нас не було і ми таких матеріалів не
виявили що стосується скажімо дискусії
по підручникам по посібникам яких часто
вусто навіть не є темою дисертації то я
хочу сказати що спеціалізована рада не
завжди розглядає розглядає те Що
виставляється на захист А те що в
порядку дискусії десь дискутується то є
тема наукової дискусії Разом з тим ми ці
всі моменти розглянули разом з
фекторськими колегами вважаємо що робота
Кириленко є має закінчений характер
і це дійсно самостійний цілісний таки
Наукова прац ми разом з тим
звертаємося з метою Забезпечення чистоти
наукових досліджень від імені нашої ради
а в нашій раді я вам хочу сказати люди
працюють заслужені не тільки з Києва це
і з кам'янсь-подільського Єсть люди це
люди єсть і інших регіонів з академій но
які очолюють методичні об'єднання секції
мають колосальний
досвід честь і я хочу сказати що ми
категорично виступаємо проти того щоб
когось очорнювати але категорично
просимо щоб і нас ніхто не очорнював Бо
коли я читаю скажімо в пресі що ми
наприклад людей які заявників які писали
звернення не запросили на засідання то в
мене документ який засвідчує що ми за с
днів заказним
м запросили цих людей мало хто ще й
передзвонив або скажімо там інші моменти
Ну я вам хочу сказати ми надали
стенограму сюди а також надали
аудіозвіт де можна повністю побачити
ретельно все що відбувалось на засіданні
стосовно того як голосували оскільки
Харків Харківський університет таємно
підтвердив наше рішення Ні не виникло
сумнівів а там закон вимагає
законодавство трьма четвертинами
підтвердження було більше навіть
оскільки в нас Одноголосно було рішення
то ми відповідь і висновок затвердили і
направили е вищ атесційних комісії для
колегії для розгляду і просимо колегію
взяти наш розглянути наше рішення взяти
його до уваги тому ми тому що ми з нам
ми вважаємо що тут особливих тем для
дискусій немає це публічна площина
політична площина і тут зупинити її
можна тільки рішеннями об'єктивними
чесними неупередженими а кожна
упередженість кожне скажімо несприйняття
один одного воно буде порочувати статті
образи чого б я не хотів я ніде не
сказав ні одного поганого слова ні про
Катерину михайлівну Кириленко ні про тих
заявників вони мали право звертатися А
ми їм даємо відповідь Дякую за
увагу Дякую Так Шановні колеги ми
приступаємо до обговорення Я ще раз Хочу
підкреслити що з приводу цього
дисертаційного
дослідження ми зараз знаходимося на
такій стадії мон запросив альтернативний
висновок спецради коли ми отримали
відповідні е запити а також
публікації цей висновок є позитивним
після того ми рухаємося в рамках
сьогоднішнього чинного законодавства і
відсилаємо цей висновок до
спеціалізованої вченої ради яка в якій
проводить захист Так це виписано
сьогодні в нормативно-правових актах
розглядають там висновок про нього про
стан розгляду доповів щойно Станіслав
Миколайович тобто він теж позитивний у
нас немає підстав порушувати питання на
атестаційній колегії про скасування
цього рішення і
позбавлення наукового ступеня але ми
маємо далі скарги і в зв'язку з цим ми
сьогодні розглядаємо це питання в нас на
на
засіданні ми можемо дискутувати
про якість нормативно-правової бази в
цьому питаннні тому що Зрозуміло що коли
ми у разі якихось застережень повертаємо
в ту саму Раду яка
присвоювала науковий ступінь то тут
є така особлива ситуація
тому ми приймаємо пропозицію ю вашу
Станіслава Миколайовича для того щоб ще
якийсь альтернативний висновок був будь
ласка ми це можемо зробити і послати ще
на один альтернативний
висновок а далі а далі має працювати
чому я сьогодні розпочала власне з
першого питання Яким чином далі має
розвиватись нормативно-правова база щоби
ми могли у випадку якихось таких колізій
говорити але в даному випадку я я хотіла
привернути увагу всіх членів
атестаційної колегії до суті до суті
оскарження і е до того чи чи
е яким який спосіб ми можемо оцінити цю
дисертацію її обговорювали науковці
визначали відсоток текстових запозичень
на даний момент е за оцінками які ми
маємо висновку такий відсоток запозичень
1,7 чи
1,4 тобто е зрозуміло що тут на
атестаційні колегії ми зараз дамо слово
тим хто хочуть щось запитати чи
вислупити але я дуже прошу щоб всіх
залишалося
все-таки об'єктивна позиція а не позиція
щоб догодити ті чи іншій стороні будь
ласка Я
запрошую до слова тих хто хочуть
висловити з
цьго прошу піднімайте руку будь ласка
прошу вам треба підійти до мікрофону
оскільки ведеться
трансляція Ну по-перше я так так
по-перше я хочу зазначити що всі ті
аргументи за якими позбавляли ступенів
інших людей представтеся і єгорченко
Ірина Анатоліївна інститут математики
Національної академії наук Пункт перший
всі ті аргументи за якими позбавляли
ступенів інших людей цілком валідні для
Катерини Кириленко всі експерти не
заперечили плагіат вони просто змінили
означення плегіату Тобто всі ці люди
яких ви тільки що позбавили ступенів
можуть так само сказати що у них
запозичення в іншому контексті що вони
не хотіли перевантажувати бібліографію
що вони посилались справжніх авторів
десь де завгодно ее
що Катерині Кириленко дозволили просто
згадати наприклад щерпину яковлєву і
потім скопіювати з незначними змінами 10
сторінок тексту це експерти змінили
означення плагіату таким чином що згадка
автора прізвища не бібліографічного
посилання потім дозволяється копіювати
кілька сторінок тексту без лапок додати
також експерти ці У пана ніколаєнка
сказали що якщо додаються фрази на мою
думку це означає опрацювання тексту і
такий дозвіл копіювати Чужий текст тобто
фактично нам атестаційна колегія тут
демонструє спеціальне ставлення до
простих людей які не мають права робити
запосичення вони там теж Я думаю
вставляли На мою думку і так далі і для
посадової дружини посадової особи
високові якій дозволено такі якісь
спеціальне означення плагіату ну це буде
враховане громадськістю далі щодо
науковості так само от були Аргументи
щодо одної з людей яких позбавили
ступенію щодо ненауковості Ну я тут не
буду говорити писав головний фізик
країни щодо
науковості ках твору пані
Кириленко наскільки мені відомо йому
відповіді не дали сама пані Кириленко
заявила У мене є
аудіозапис про те що необхідно викладати
позанаукові тобто псевдонаукові знання
ее студентам для того щоб вони
формулювали цілісну картину освіту тобто
затвердження сьогодні е дисертації пані
Кириленко означає що Міністерство освіти
так само погоджується з викладанням по
позанаукових знань значить підручники за
якими захищена дисертація які є
предметом дисертації містять Саме ці
позанаукові знання всі посібники і
підручники містять оці ну дуже дивні
тексти про лентони які навіть до
псевдонауки означення не мають Це просто
ну якісь я не знаю що це таке навіть це
важко сказати Ну але очевидно що
Міністерство освіти також вважає що
цьому потрібно вчити студентів значить
про те що були розглянуті всі зауваження
паном Ніколаєнко він сказав це не правда
зауважень пані Пархоменко 100 сторінок
їхні висновки просто мають набагато
менший обсяг і всі зауваження не були
розглянуті
ее наші зауваження щодо фіктивних
публікацій не були розглянуті е і на
солузасіданні колеги Тобто спецради де
ми були Ну нам просто затикали там
навіть не дали про це сказати токо
значить статистичний аналіз типу один
скількість там відсотків
ее ну взагалі застосування статистичного
аналізу для аналізу економічної чесності
говорить тільки про некваліфікованість
людей які це говорять Це абсолютно не
має стосунку статистичний аналіз може
використовуватись для аналізу
копірайтингу тобто як платять людям які
там сайтих заповнюють Це просто
нерелевантно абсолютно довідка у яку
згадував пан Ніколаєнко на засіданні
спецради це довідка за базою дисертацій
пані Кириленко ніхто не звинувачував
копі копіювання українських дисертації
Там значить і
нормальний програмне забезпечення для
аналізу плагіату академічного робить
таблиці таблиці зроблені руками там
продемонстровано десь Ну приблизно 30%
плагіату таблиці на 100 сторінок
тобто за
22% позбавляють ступеня за 30 Ну все
нормально і ще один момент щодо
рекомендованих листів ці листи Ми не
отримали Тобто ми маємо також випадок
фальсифікації якщо ці листи були
направлені і ви маєте якісь документи з
нашими підписами це
фальсифікація будь ласка покажіть ми
підемо в міліцію і напишемо відповідні
заяви Дуже дякую Я дуже сподіваюсь що
атестаційни комісія все-таки не зафіксує
сьогодні банкрутство освітньої системи
української і прийме справедливе
рішення пані Ірино пані Ірино перш за
все от ви користуєтесь такими
узагальненнями так такими ну це на рівні
політичної заяви про банкрутство освіми
так са дозвіл на п є конруцію освітньої
системи у нас є ми можемо дискутувати
про те що Та треба удосконалювати
законода так так було б дуже добре
якщоби факти які ви щойно назвали були
підтверджені такими офіційними
висновками Які ви отримали сьогодні з
приводу попередніх трьох дисертаційних
досліджень які ви ставите в один ряд але
Нано слід від від цього випадку який ми
зараз розглядаємо там ми маємо реальні
судові експертизи Там ми маємо документи
на які ми можемо покладатися До чого ви
зараз нас закликаєте ви закликаєте
атестаційну колегнів без реальних
документівку яких є є публікації є
табличка публікацій але в нас не немає
висновку хоча б якогось О так як
представино наприклад уку по дисертації
чи інші ее в тихто трьох справах Я
розумію що ви зараз скажете про простих
людей наприклад ректора луганського
університету
так який працює в Луганську який проста
людина і якого На жаль ми не ну він
проста блавка і якого На жаль ми не
змогли запросити сюди щоб він тут
захищав свої інтереси при цьому маючи
офіційні висновки про не тільки плагіат
але й не науковість і низьки низький
рівень цього
дослідження так само як і працівник який
очолює фінансовий підрозділ служби
безпеки України тобто не потрібно
пересмикувати факти ми готові розглядати
достовірну інформацію яка підтверджена
відповідними інституціями але не може
бути одне голослівне звинувачення таким
який має яке має вирішувати долю людини
або п Ну вводити в оману інших людей ми
готові далі дискутувати але по потрібно
мати інші висновки у нас зараз висновок
висновки від офіційних інституцій які
підтверджували всі ваші тези немає і я
зараз повинна надати слово Катерині
Кириленко тому що вона теж має
правоня Ну я ще два слова скажу два
слова я ще скажу що фактично ці експерти
розширили означення неплагіату вони
підтвердили якщо правильно читати їхні
висновки і спецрада нубі і спецрада
Харківська підтвердили що там є
некоректні запозичення просто вони
змінили означення плагату таким чином що
ці текстові запозичення не є плагатом
тобто тут все що
відбулось будь ласка Так чи є пані
Катерина так
що є шили бажаюч виступити я не
наполягаю на тому щоб вони ї
ви
гаразд добре Тобто
ви щоб спочатку дати того хто наполягає
тоді будете ви виступати будь ласка
Людина
це пані Тетяна паркоменко будь ласкари
порядку сказали за зако будь ласка
Катерина я маєте прошу там де є
мікрофон Шановний пане пані міністр
Шановні члени колегії шановні присутні
Тема моєї дисертації теоретичні
методичні основи формування інноваційної
культури майбутніх культурологів у
вищому навчальному закладі дисертація
захищена із галузі педагогіки за
спеціальністю
13004 теорія і методика професійної
освіти змістом педагогічного дослідження
як відомо є перепрошую за тавтологію
зміст навчання і виховання дисертація є
результатом моєї 20 річної педагогічної
діяльності в одному ВУЗі у ній викладені
результати експерименту часові рамки
якого торкалися від 2004 до 2014
року в ході дослідження розроблена
модель формування інноваційної культури
майбутніх культурологів і відповідно
описані результати педагогічного
експерименту який був присвячений її
впровадженню на на початку свого
дисертаційного
дослідження в констатувальній його
частині я окреслюю соціально педагогічні
умови в яких відбувається моє
дослідження і здійснює уточнення понять
відповідно до завдань свого дослідження
так от от в цій частині не головній
частині дослідження і починаються
обговорення в рамках висвітлення
соціально-педагогічних умов дослідження
я висвітлює соціалізова науковий дискурс
у якому відбувається мій педагогічний
експеримент я намагаюся це зробити
максимально наближено до того змісту
наукового дискурсу яким володію я
володіють інші володіють володіє власне
і студент і
експерт для цього я використовую типові
визначення і формулювання Які мої так
звані експерти вишуковують у праці інших
авторів і називають підмінюючі поняття
хоча в цьому звинувачують інших маю на
увазі в підміні понять називають це так
званим плагіато
е-е якщо в ході свого педагогічного
дослідження Я буду сама визначати умови
його здійснення і сама формулювати
поняття якими оперує то це вплине на
частоту цього дослідження і локалізує
його результат тому використання
подібних загальних термінів є
обумовленим метою досліджен праці
науковців які я використовую у цьому
процесі висвітлення
соціально-педагогічних умов я цитую у
інших своїх наукових працях які
виносяться на запис і частина яких
увійшла в Текст дисертації ці цитування
в самому тексті дисертації були зняті
оскільки в ході дослідження було
виявлено що подібні формулювання і
визначення не є ексклюзивними вони вони
зустрічаються у текстах багатьох інших
авторів тим більше наприкінці кожного
розділу своєї дисертації я пишу що
матеріал викладений в даному розділі був
результа детально викладений в таких-то
таких-то працях автор потім коли я
уточнюю зміст понять яким оперую
наголошую не розробляю не встановлюю
авторство а уточнюю зміст понять в
частині уточнення змісту понятть я
апріорі оріту користуюся тими термінами
що і інші науковці мої так звані опонент
починають шукати текстові
співпадіння які називають плагіатом у
праці величезної кількості авторів Хочу
наголосити що такий пошук носить
псевдонауковий характер оскільки до
уваги беруться ті праці які перебувають
у цифровому які оцифровані в цифровому
му вигляді праці науковці які є
першочерговими до цих праць А ті що
оцифровані є похідним не беруться до
уваги зокрема у зверненні йшлося що мій
аналіз е дефініції новаційної культури
запозичений із статті Соболь яка була
опублікована у журналі молодий вчини
14го року і в статті кузьміной насправді
ці праці є наслідком опрацювання
попередньої роботи 2009 року у
журналі проблеми науки такого дослідника
як коюда і якої немає цієї праці у
цифровому варіанті тому мова йде власне
про такий досить специфічний аналіз
тексту який має бути оцінений
спеціалістами щодо суті дослідження суті
дослідження є розробка моделі формування
інноваційної культури майбутніх
культуролог центральним компонентом
моделі яка розроблена є впровадження в
реальний освітній процес інноваційних
мультидисциплінарних дидактичних
комплексів з якими працює Вища школа
провідних країн світу нині оскільки такі
мультидисциплінарні дидактичні комплекси
дозволяють систематизувати знання які
отримує студент у формі відкритої
системи до перекомпоновки до
перемоделювання і ці знання дозволяє І
така і такий підхід до навчального
процесу дозволяє доповнити цю систему
знань новим знанням так от в умовах
індустріального суспільства Перепрошую
постіндустріального суспільства
інформаційного суспільства знанневого
суспільства потреба у працівниках чи в
просто в спеціалістах які здатні на
перманентну освіту які здатні на те щоби
пропонувати інноваційний креативний
продукт впроваджувати його як успішний
продукт є дуже високою для цього мною
щоби в сфері культури ми могли
сформувати підготувати таких працівників
був розроблений впроваджений в реальний
освітній простір інноваційний
мультидисциплінарний дидактичний
комплекс який назива названий мною
культура і наука в цьому
мультидисциплінарному синкратичному
навчальному навчально-методичному
комплексі на основі авторського мого
потлумачення наскрізних ключових понять
таких як картина світу природнича
природничо науковокартина світу
гуманітарна картина світу інноваційна
культура на основі впровадження е
синергетичного і особистісного підходу в
освіті
е з метою формування цілісної наукової
картини світи і цілісних знань у
студентів йде мова про об'єднання в
освітньому просторі про залучення в
освітній просторі як наукового так і
позанаукового знання Як природничого так
і гуманітарного знання і оскільки в
моєму дослідженні увага приділя ляється
не лише процесуальній його частині а й
змістовій то в роботі наведено як
ілюстративний приклад одну Тео одну із
теорій ознайомитися з якою на
варіативній основі пропонується студента
ця теорія належить не мені вона належить
українській дослідниці наголошую доктору
філософських наук завідуючий кафедрою
соціальної педагогіки і гендерних студій
Сумського державного педагогічного
університету е дослідниці на ім'я
Щербина Якова ця дослідниця говорить про
можливість обґрунтування фізичного
існування Бога в результаті
прийняття на за основу припущення про те
що субелементарні часточки лептони мають
психічні
властивості наголошую для фізиків і
математиків які активно долучились до
обговорення цього питання ще раз на тому
що ця теорія належить не мені я її
використовую як ілюстративний приклад у
своєму дослідженні з метоюмо
демонстрації можливості доповнення
наукового знання Поза науковими знаннями
е внаслідку внаслідок реалізації цієї
синергетичної концепції науки освіти що
нині є провідною у науці заявники
обговорювали і підручник цієї дисципліни
хочу сказати що підручник є книжною
формою навчального матеріалу у
підручнику згідно закону про авторські
право і суміжні права 23 стаття
передбачає що використання наукового
твору з метою його на викладання не є
плагіатом так от у цьому
підручнику який носить синкретичний
характер відповідно до своїх наскрізних
бачень наскріз до свого бачення
наскрізних питань я я перекомпоновую
знання багатьох галузей знань з якими
пропоную ознайомитися студентам
підручник не перебуває в вільному
продажі підручник не має грефу
Міністерства освіти і науки це робочий
матеріал для студентів які слухають курс
що є авторським і матеріали до якого
вони можуть взяти лише у викладача автор
який опанує цьому підручнику як І власне
іншим моїм статтям Пархоменко Тетяна
Сергіївна немає підручника власно
авторства жодного і тому напевне не знає
про специфіку написання підручників як і
специфіку навчальної літератури Я до
речі поцікавилася колом наукових
інтересів даного автора і з'ясувала що
за останніх пть років Пархоменко Тетяна
Сергіївна має дві публікації із них одна
- це матеріали конференції обидві вони
року я оголошу тему цих публікацій
оскільки вона на мою думку думку
Сподіваюся і на думку
присутніх м'яко каже м'яко кажучи не
відповідає темі досліджень мого
дослідження тема статті з історії
колекціонування фарфору в Європі тема
тес-конференції культурний статус
фарфору в Європі попередня публікація
датується 2010 роком і носить назву
попсвіти як елемент мас культури ще
попередня публікація даного автора 7мого
року і носить назву міжнародний туризм
як провідна індустрія X
століття хочу сказати на завершення про
опонентів так званих які активізувалися
досить активно вже після того коли мною
був отриманий диплом доктора
педагогічних наук в той час коли
дисертація як зазначалося була у
вільному доступі із вересня 15го року
захищена у жовтні 15го року
некомпетентність цих так званих
опонентів була засвідчена двома вченними
радами профільними вченними радами
сьогоднішній розгляд моєї дисертації -
це вже третій розгляд цієї дисертації
після її захисту на спеціалізованій
вченій раді
а зауважені цих опонентів носять не лише
псевдонауковий характер а подекуди
межують із здоровим глуздом у листі
Пархоменко Тетяни Сергіївни який вона
направила до спеціалізованої вченої ради
у Харків а напів абзацу була цитата про
наступне я не буду цитувати але копія У
мене є і можу
надати в реченні де прізвище дослідника
на
ім'я зараз я Олександр
постряков яке вживається в родовому
відмінку що в українській мові звучить
як поскрякова згадується прац багатьох
дослідників поскрякова автор звернення
робить висновок що я як науковець назива
ваю чоловіка жінкою і його навіть в очі
не бачить такий характер зауважень можна
наводити багато тому що ними майориці
маярять всі ці звернення треба сказати
також що всі ці зауваження носять
постійно змінний
характер варіативна складова в них
присутня більшою ніж потрібному мірою і
все це нагадує відомий вислів із відомої
байки про те що ты виноватож тем что
хоче мнікуши неважливо Які зауваження
ливо що все
погано та наполегливість з якою так
звані
опоненти постійно пролонгують це питання
на мою думку свідчить про замовний і
упереджений характер цих публікацій і
цих звернень хочу сказати що почалося це
після того коли мене почали сприймати не
як науковця з 20тирічним стажем роботи а
як дружину посадовця який нині є
посадовцем але інформую що коли я одруж
ми були аспірантами тому корупційна
складова яка вишукується в в цій частині
думаю є фіктивно звинувачення у плагіаті
На мою адресу носять замовний характер в
їх основі лежать маніпулятивні
технології зауваження не торкаються
головної частини досліджень А ті
історичні публікації які з'являються на
сторінках не зовсім коректних
інтернет-видань з боку окремих осіб
нагадують пошук чорної кішки ній кімнаті
де Вона відсутня тому для того щоб
завершити свій виступ на позитивній ноті
все-таки хочеться побажати моїм так
званим опонентам Із такою ж заповзятістю
взятися за написання власних наукових
праць які Ну напевно будуть еталонними
для наукового простору оскільки автори
дуже розуміються на методиці написання
наукових робіт і на різних векторах
наукового дослідження якщо є до мене
запитання я відповім Я намагалася бути
лаконічно якщо не вийшло вибачте
дякую Катерина Михайлівна ми ще
поставимо вам запитання але я маю надати
слово пакоменку І після того вже будуть
запитання Прошу пані
тя Доброго дня шановна пані міністр
Доброго дня вельми поважні члени
атестаційної колегії Доброго дня всі
присутні я почну з того обвинувачення
яке ви пані міністре висловили на адресу
моєї колежанки Ірини єгорченко про те що
відсутні документи в міністерстві які б
давали вам можливість прийняти виважене
рішення це не відповідає дійсності адже
10 грудня 2015 року за 5 днів до
засідання атестаційної колегії яка
затвердила присудження наукового ступеню
доктора наук пані Кириленко мною бу була
написана офіційна заява і подана за
допомогою народного депутата яка в свою
чергу на основі моєї офіційної заяви
написала запит народного депутата до
Міністерства освіти 11 числа до мене
мені пере переказали прохання від
заступника міністра тодішнього Андрія
гевка переслати йому всі ті документи
про яких йшлося в додатках до цієї моєї
заяви від 10 грудня при спроби переслати
йому pdf-файли а він просив звести їх
єдиний файл я з'ясувала що це технічно
неможливо і відписалась йому в інтернеті
що я цього зробити не можу але готова в
понеділок адже 11 грудня було п'ятниця в
понеділок 14 грудня привести йому
роздруківки тих першоджерел з яких було
встановлено запозичення буквальне
запозичення тексту в дисертації пані
Кириленко на той момент на 100 сторінках
її докторської
дисертації 14 грудня тобто за день до
засідання атестаційної колегії близько
12 години дня я привезла і передала в
кабінеті тодішнього заступника міністра
пану панові Гевко ці
роздруківки не просто роздруківки а
тексти в якій було маркером мною
виділені фрагменти а інколи це було
просто повністю статті тобто десятки
сторінок з вказівкою на полях цих
роздруківок сторінок і навіть абзаців
дисертації пані Катерини Кириленко що
причому пан Гевко в моїй присутності
почав звірку тих документів які Я надала
а також таблиці зведеної в меї прису
тністі звірку з паперовим носієм
дисертації пані Кириленко Таким чином я
ставлю всіх присутніх до відома що 14
грудня за день до засідання тієї
атестаційної колегії Міністерство освіти
в особі пана гевка отримала від мене
документи не таблиці порівнянні тобто
таблиця само собою але ще роздруківки
повторюють тих першо джерел з яких було
мною особисто в ручному порядку я не
зверталась до жодних програм встановлено
плагіат на 100 сторінках дисертації пані
Кириленко наскільки мені відомо
відбулась затримка реєстрації моєї заяви
яка була очевидно
невипадково
зареєстровано 15 числа як було написано
в мене є документи синхронно засіданням
вашої ну точніше атестаційної колегії
мон очевидно ця маніпуляція
дозволила не повідомити членів
атестаційної колегії про наявність
плеяту на 100 сторінках дисертації пані
Кириленко Таким чином будь ласка
поцікавтеся де зникли ті документи які я
передавала панові гевку більше того за
годину після цього відбулась розмова з
його ініціативи Я не хочу на даний
момент переказувати цей зміст але
внаслідок цієї розмови я сказала якщо ви
не будете застосовувати надані мною
документи будь ласка поверніть їх Мені
вони є моєю власністю в тому числі і
інтелектуальною на що було запевнено що
ні вони будуть використані в
роботі про те що не було до е не було
повідомлення членів атестаційної колегі
Я вже дізналася за значним спізнанням
адже на всі мої і не тільки мої запити
то Яким є результат розгляду цього
питання з врахуванням моїх документів
Міністерство ну точніше пан Гевко
відмовчувався аж до поки врешті-рештні
з'явилось офіційне рішення Мом на сайті
з чого я з'ясувала що ці документи не
були взяті до розгляду мені через
декілька днів повернули мої документи
Але я маю підставу стверджувати що вони
стали доступні пані Катерині Кириленко
на якій час вона ними користувалась але
вона ними користувалася тому що з цього
витікають дуже важливі вже кримінальні
моменти але я про це сьогодні говорити
не
буду Наступне Що стосується подальшого
розгляду
А на момент е коли мені стало відомо що
тим не менш Рішення було позитивним Я
звернулася вдруге з офіційною заявою на
ім'я іміністра Квіта
про те що на той момент це
кінець січня ви плагіат мною було
виявлено вже на 130 сторінках цієї
дисертації А на момент коли її
дисертація була надіслано до Харкова я 9
березня відправила поштою бандероль з
усіма знов таки роздрукованими
першоджерелами на ім'я пана голову
спецради прокопенка і надіслали
роздруківки першо джерел які містили
дані по плагіату вже на понад 160
сторінках дисертації пані кероленко
більше того я заявляю що на даний момент
з всіх 160 сторінок 100 сторінок є
плагіатом або повністю вся сторінка або
не менше половини у мене з собою тільки
перелік плагіату в дисертації пані
Кириленко в підручнику культура і наука
в чотирьох посібниках виданих В 13-му
році в кількох статтях надрукованих
фахових виданнях принаймні в тих статтях
які подані нею в авторефераті як такі що
відображають основний зміст дисертації а
також в монографії яка До речі не
надходила на момент захисту до тих
бібліотек включаючи книжкову палату і
з'явилася в книжковій палаті лише 19
лютого цього тобто 16го року от навіть і
в цій монографії повторюю лише перелік
становить понад 50
сторінок витяг цього переліку якщо кому
буде цікаво Я готови надати просто зараз
це 28 сторінок але це витяг в основному
тих джерел які або частково відоме але
невідоми тепер
щодо інших
моментів при розгляді дисертації при
прийняття до розгляду і розгляду
дисертації пані
Кириленко спеціалізованою вченою радою
д-26
20418 в нубіб було порушено низку
нормативно-правових документів які
регулюють атестацію наук кадрів зокрема
положення про спеціалізовану вчену Раду
порядку присудження наукових ступенів в
наступних
частинах Ну ви знаєте що згідно
положення про спеціалізовану вчену Раду
спеціалізована вченна рада обирає
комісію з трьох осіб для встановлення
відповідності
профілю висновок про науковий рівень
дисертації відповідністю профілю Ради
кількість обсяг публікацій та повноту
опублікованих матеріалів якщо ми
залишимо навіть плеяд а в іншому місці
порядку присудження наукових ступенів
вимагається від докторської дисертації
аби людина яка захищається була
суб'єктом авторського права щодо
результатів дослідження от якщо навіть
це ми залишаємо за
межами то щодо такого пункту як
кількість обсяг публікації та про
повноту опублікованих матеріалів
дисертацій було
порушено наказ 1112 мон який є чинним Як
ви знаєте і додатків до ньго вимоги дві
вимоги там існують в частині Отже ви
знаєте вимагається не менше 20
публікацій у фахових виданнях України з
яких не менше чотирьох публікацій у
наукових періодичних виданнях інших
держав з напряму з якого підготовлену
дисертацію якщо ви відкриєте автореферат
або дисертацію пані Кириленко то вона
наводить серед тих робіт які
відображають основний зміст дисертації А
у вступі до реферату і дисертації пише
наступне Отже 10 статей сім посібників
один підручник і чотири в зарубіжних
виданнях перше щодо статей у вітчизняних
виданнях
насправді лише сім з них з того переліку
пане греба відповідає вимогам цих
нормативних документів пояснюю таке така
публікація як концепція людини та
культури Карла Роджера До речі насправді
Роджерс а не Роджер яка указана на
сторінці 30 автореферату під номером
третім яка нібито надрукована у віснику
КНУКіМ випуск перший за
1999 рік є неправдою адже такий випуск
існує але в ньому немає цієї або якоїсь
іншої статті пані
Кириленко
наступне дві публікації які також також
подаються публікації в фахових виданнях
це публікації за номером
1516 насправді надруковані в наукових
виданнях Київського національного
університету культури і мистецтв які не
є фаховими з педагогіки вони є фахоми
скульптурології і
мистецтвознавства ще раз наголошую Таким
чином з того переліку лише формально сім
відповідають вимогам зазначених
нормативно-правових
документів з цих статей також не всі
тобто з тих що формально відповідають
тим не менше зновтаки посилаюсь на наказ
1112 мон в якому зокрема пишеться не
зараховуються публікації в яких
повторюються наукові результати
опубліковані раніше в публікаціях що в
війшли до мінімальної кількості
публікацій за темою дисертацію в такому
разі кількість фахових кількість статей
пані Кириленко у фахових виданнях
автоматично зменшується до п'яти
оскільки публікації за номером 5 10 і 11
повністю або переважно повторюють
наукові результати що дозволяє
зарахувати з трх трьох статей лише
одну До речі серед цих п'яти статей
одна тобто з тих що формально
відповідають вимогам наказу 11 12 в
одній це спільна стаття з науковим
консультантом паном грідченка міститься
плагіат який сягає половину цієї статті
і джерелом якого виступили шість
публікацій українських російських і
білоруських
авторів наступне з чотирьох статей
поданих в авторефераті пані Кириленко
під рубрикою публікацію зарубіжних
виданнях одна стаття як з'ясувала моя
колега Ірина єгорченко надругована у
надруковано у фейковому виданні тобто в
такому яке не існує реально а
виготовляється на замовлення конкретного
клієнта ще дві статті тобто ті які
нібито в зарубіжних виданнях це статті в
періодичних наукових виданнях Київського
національного університету імені Тараса
Шевченка в гуманітарній студії і вісник
КНУ імені Тараса
Шевченка дійсно існує положення яке
дозволяє дорівнювати статті в
науковометричних виданнях України до
фахових Ну якщо вони є науковометричними
ці два видання внесені до російського
індексу наукового цитування але
але серія філософія і політологія таким
чином це є непрофільні видання і вони не
можуть бути зараховані згідно
відповідних нормативних документів Таким
чином до п'яти поперед статей додається
одна з тих так званих зарубіжних що
разом складає шість відомо також що
положенням про присудження наукових
ступенів прирівнюються посібники до
публікації якщо йдеться про дисертації з
педагогічних наук звертаю вашу увагу що
йдеться про посібники а не про підручник
Таким чином підручник навіть формально
не може бути зарахований до цього списку
що стосується посібників пані Кириленко
визначає їх кількість в якості сіми у
вступі до дисертації у вступі до
автореферату але в списку самого
наприкінці автореферату насправді шість
з чих з цих чотирьох Перепрошую з цих
шести
посібників лише два формально
відповідають вимогам зазначеного
документу щодо чотирьох решта виданих в
13-му році то Я стверджую і до можу
довести адже в мене за сфотографовані
всі безвинятка її публікації що вони
дублюють один одного або повністю або
близько до половини Таким чином знов
таки повертаємося до наказу 1112 і з цих
чотирьох посібників насправді від можемо
зарахувати їй лише
один пані Тетяно Скажіть будь ласка
скільки вам ще потрібно часу для вашого
вис до вечра Все з мене з вас достатньо
Дякую Шановні колеги ми почули зараз
будемо ставити питання Я єдине хотіла б
оскільки ви назвали Моє прізвище і
сказали про те що я звинуватила вашу
колегу пані Ірину по-перше Я не в суді і
нікого не звинувачую по-друге що я чітко
сказала що ми не маємо таких рішень не
особистофізичної особи якою ви є і зараз
ви стверджуєте свої висновки і це є ваша
суб'єктивна думка але ми не маємо
висновків наукових інституцій
спеціалізованих вчених рад які ми мали в
попередніх трьох випадках і ми ці
висновки демонстрували і ми ці висновки
можемо взяти відповідно до
нормативно-правової бази до уваги от що
я говорила самеце я говорила Я впевнена
що пані Ірина прекрасно розуміє різницю
між заявою від фізичної особи яка яка є
як звернення до Міністерства і висновком
спеціалізованої вченої ради або наукової
установи от що ми маємо на увазі в цьому
є принципова різниця між тими
документами якими ми керуємося і
зверненням тому що крім цього звернення
є ще інші звернення і в кожному
зверненні є суб'єктивна думка під яку
необхідно отримати спочатку Докази і
висновки наукової спільноти тому що
наприклад коли ви говорите що наукові
результати чи сфальсифіковані чи ці
наукові результати не є актуальними то
про актуальність не згадувала нічого
Гаразд сфальсифіковані так яке слово
вами було вшито це повинна сказати
відповідна експертна Наукова спільнота
тобто ті люди які займаються даною
тематикою і які компетентні робити
висновки з приводу наукових результатів
даної дисертації тому я реагую зараз на
те чи Чим ви апелювали до мене будь
ласка ви просите слово Дозвольте репліку
Я теж маю
відреагувати якщо ви відреагували я теж
маю відреагувати зокрема на
обвинувачення пана николаєнка про те що
він по відомих завчасною і так далі от
будь ласка лист який надійшов мені як
апелянту по цій справі де зазначено
що Мене запрошують точніше інформують
вас що розгляд вашого звернення на
засіданні спеціалізованої вченої ради
де2620418 відбудеться 10 червня 2016
року о 13 годині він написаний
30.06 порахуйте будь ласка скільки днів
пройшло нагаду ю вам що згідно пункту 91
положення про спеціалізовану вчену Раду
запрошення апелянту надсилається не
менше ніж за 10 днів не менше ніж за 10
днів за с днів тільки вийшло на конверті
взагалі дата четвертого я без претензій
пан Ніколаєнко повідомив за 5 хвилин я
встала встигла взяти авто Подзвонити
своїм колегам іми взяли таксі і приїхали
але тепер я хочу звернутись до пана
греби який відповідав на мою заяву своїм
листом Я те що отримала можу пред'явити
ви віднесли розгляд моєї апеляційної
справи в шановному НУБіП до восьмого
розділу положення про спеціалізовану
вчену Раду Добре хай буде восьмий розділ
але я перепрошую я
перепрошую вам лист вас
показати я
завершую ціного статусу апелянта немає
щоб ви розуміли те що вам надали слово
будь ласка дотримуйтеся регламенту це
спасибі зачемне по крім того коли вас па
Ніколаєнко як ви кажете повідомляв У вас
нема офіційного статусу ні апелянта ні
експерта У вас є власна думка яку ми з
задоволенням вислухали ми розуміємо що у
вас високий статус після написання Якої
роботи по фарфору вам надає можливість
зробити свій висновк і по дисертації
будь ласка у вас дуже красиво це
виходить Напишіть ще окрему дисертаці як
да зна Дозвольте відповісти на вашу
репліку по-перше ви пога ви ви добре ви
почули що сказала пані Катерина про
фарфор але будь ласка поцікавтесь
пожалуйста великою українську
енциклопедію в якій надруковано декілька
моїх статей чомусь згадка про велику
українську енциклопедію виявились недоро
недоречно це по-перше по-друге пане
греба ви мені написали офіційний лист де
посилаєтесь на восьмий розділ положення
про спеціалізовану вчену Раду в які в
якому ідеться про розгляд питання про
скасування наукового ступеню Окей Хай
буде так тоді Я повідомляю офіційно що
спеціалізована вчена рада в
НУБіП на засідання 10 червня цього року
порушила пункт яким передбачається
таємне голосування рішення після
обговорення адже обидва голосування на
цьому засідання були
відкритими що я і доводжу до вашого
Відома і останнє ви заперечуєте Мій
статус офіційного апелянта даремно 29
січня мною було зареєстровано ще одна
офіційна заява вже на рішення
атестаційної колегії Мом будь ласка
зверніться до вашої канцелярії що надає
мені автоматично статус апелянта Дякую
за
увагу так ее
Дякую я лише хотіла б уточнити пані
Тетяно е в нас є заявник який пише
заяву у нас немає статусу
апелянта можна тоді розглядати всіх
заявників які з звертається до
Міністерства освіти і науки з якимись
скаргами зі статусом апелянта Я хочу
розумієте відбувається дуже багато
словесних маніпуляцій і це неправильно
якщо ми прагнемо дійсно справедливості
то тоді треба бути справді справедливим
а не займатися такими е
комбінаціями тому що Наприклад якщо ми
говоримо про таємне голосування то
таємне голосування стосується рішення
спеціалізованої вченої ради про
присвоєння наукового ступеня от де є в
нас написане таємне голосування
позбавлення чи чи позбавлення чи
позбавлення якщо на це є підстави тобто
я хочу зрозуміти ви розумієте Ви
вимагаєте ніби справедливості ось тут
Вас так красиво знімають камери
спеціальна підсвітка саме для вас с
робиться так щоб було добре видно тобто
ну відчувається підготовленість цієї
акції Але разом з тим ви займаєтеся
певними маніпуляціями я відверто кажучи
очікувала більше якихось реальних фактів
ніж те що ми зараз почули Але я думаю що
давайте ми зараз Шановні колеги
поставимо Ще запитання Я думаю що членів
атестаційної колегії є Які запитання і
там піднімали ще руку щоб не вийшло так
що ми Комусь не дали слово будь ласка
дякуюку я зактаю до регламенту Я розумію
що якщо ми тільки вас зупинимо ви потім
нас звинуватите що ми обірвали вас на
пів слові Я думаю що зараз всі бачили що
ми не обривали вас на пів слові бо
потім Можемо і таке почути Дякую Аліна
Світлана Миколаївна доктор педагогічних
наук професор національної університе те
біоресурсів і природокористування
оскільки я очолювала комісію яка
проводила попередній розгляд матеріалів
які були надійслані мікрофон будь
ласка На
кнопочку оскільки я
очолювала комісію яка проводила
попередній розгляд матеріалів які
надійшли до нашої спеціалізованої вченої
ради то Дозвольте сказати кілька слів не
зложиваючи вашою увагою було озвучено що
на спеціалізова на засіданні
спеціалізовани вче ради 10 червня не
було повністю розглянуто всі надані
матеріали це неправда комісія працювала
цілий місяць і на 52-х сторінках які є в
документах було зроблено певні висновки
крім того є якщо ми говоримо про Факти є
у нас довідки про статистичний аналіз за
допомогою програмних засобів що
стосується аналізу і перевірки на
наявність плагіату чи запозичень е-е
далі якщо ми говоримо про закон Ми
повинні послуговуватись законом і
заявники е апелюють до закону про
авторське право та суміжні права в тій
частині де говориться про те що навіть
частина твору захищається як
інтелектуальна власність але наступна
стаття дозволю собі процитувати говорить
про те що за цим законом охорона не
поширюється на будь-яку ідею процедуру
метод процес концепцію відкриття винахід
корисну модель промисловий зразок знак
для товарів і послуг раціоналізаторську
пропозицію звичайні дані навіть якщо
вони виражені описані
пояснені проілюстровані у творі тощо
тому якщо ми говоримо про теорію
лептонів чи про будь-які інші приклади
тому ми повинні розглядати їх тільки
саме в цьому контексті це не виноситься
як науковий результат і відповідно
комісія так і розглядала ці
моменти далі якщо ми говоримо говоримо
про те що тут такі гучні заяви
прозвучали про фейкові публікації і таке
інше я хочу сказати що у нас крім
спеціалізованої вченої ради
відповідальних осіб є спеціальний відділ
наукової атестації який займається
попереднім розглядом документів до того
як вони подаються в Раду перевіряє
наявність оригіналів усіх публікацій і я
можу запевнити що всі оригінали були
представлені Інакше ця дисертація в Раду
би не була прийнята і не розглядалась би
далі що стосується іще деяких неприємно
про це говорити але деяких моментів
дозволю собі теж сказати що заявники які
були присутні на засіданні 10 червня
вони мали змогу повністю вислухати
висловити свою думку ми їх
висловали вислухали ми не переривали род
не затикала як було тут сказано але
натомість з боку наприклад Ірини
Анатоліївни єгорченко про прозвучало хоч
вона сама і визнала у відповідь на
запитання що вона некомпетентна у галузі
педагогічних наук але критикувати може
але прозвучали заяви
такого змісту ваша рада некомпетентна
Харківська рада некомпетентна
Міністерство некваліфіковане це не
голослівні заяви є відеозапис При
бажанні можна подивитися всі ці
моменти І на останок хотілось би сказати
що якщо теж заявники апелюють І ми
говоримо зараз про академічну
доброчесність ми орієнтуємось на те що
відбувається в Європі У розвинених
країнах як розглядаються ці питання То
як приклад наводилося позбавлення
міністра освіти Німеччини Анет шаван
докторського титулу Так це було але Це
відбувалось коректно це відбувалось за
рішенням філософського факультету
дюсельдольського університету і коли
пані шаван після прийняття цього рішення
про позбавлення її докторського ти
титулу Так там звучить запропонували
опублікувати матеріали у пресі щоб зняти
деякі питання вона відмовилась і це її
побажання було враховано матеріали
опубліковані не були що стосується ж іще
одного як приклад звинувачення на адресу
міністра оборони урсули фонделяйн теж у
Німеччині то вища медична школа гановера
розглянула і я останнє дозволю теж собі
процитувати розглянула її матеріали і
вона з гла вчиний ступінь незважаючи на
те що було дослівно цитую зазначено про
допущені помилки в дисертації пов'язані
з некоректними запозиченнями оскільки це
були помилки а не зловмиста поведінка і
вони не впливають на основний зміст
дисертаційної роботи тому хотілось би
закликати до об'єктивності І побажати
щоб розгляди таких дисертацій і таких
питань були Нам всім на користь
дякую дякую Так Шановні колеги колеги я
відкриваю зараз час для питань прошу
тільки вказати кому саме ви ставите ці
питання прошу члени атестаційної колеги
Прошу В мене є до пана ніколаєнка
питання Скажіть будь ласка якінебудь
експертні висновки не залежні підкреслюю
експертні висновки документ який має
офіційне значення ми входили до вашої до
вашої вченої ради спеціалізованої ради і
де було казано що є
плагіато в роботі пані риле
Я дякую за запитання за 60 своїх років
життя негативу не вислухав як протягом
спілкування з деякими заявниками
ми ніяких експертних висновків крім
висновків Харківського спецради по
професі педагогіка профсіняї освіті
Харківського національного державного
університету не отримували до нашої
спецради перед захистом під час захисту
не звертався жоден вчени Я до речі хочу
сказати не хотів це говорити але там
сидить також доктор науки Що Петро
Григорович який задає математику яка тут
виступала одне просте питання Скажіть
будь ласка ви оцінили докторську роботу
із науки якої ви некомпетентні скажіть
будь ласка якими ви критеріями науковими
послуговувались оцінці відповідь проста
Я жодного критерія не знаю я вам
прокручу час кіно але там все написано
неправильно тепер мене ззначуть що я там
когось перебивав я хочу сказати
українському загалу і вам що знімаєте
Дивіться що все правильно згавили коли
ми порахували скільки виступав я і
заявники то вони в чотири рази більше
мене говорили єдине що я зробив Ми дали
всім по 5 хвилин вони всі виступали
чотири три-чотири регламента і нас пробу
зробить зауваження називалися затикають
рок ну люди добреі Це ж можна з ума
зійти коли тебе просто Ні за що вважають
ну скільки ж можна я яке відношення маю
до вашої внутрівидової боротьби ви
б'єтеся за посаду ректора в університеті
А ми тут крайні всі залишаємося Ну я маю
університет ми ставились до роботи рівно
члени спецради нашої не зважали Хто де
працює жорстка була оцінка дискусія 3 1
по години люди добрі Приходьте кажіть Ми
раді вас слухати але я прошу не
ображайтесь в мене ще одне питання до
пана губерського сказали що університет
Шевченко видає видання які Чи фейковими
чи напівфейковими це правда чи неправда
[музика]
будь
ласка Я стасла миколайови хотів зати
питанняла Миколайович Скажіть будь ласка
в вашій раді представники докторська
рада Я так розумію педагогчно так у вас
представники чисто з вашого університета
чи із інших тут не може бути я ю що не
може бути в нас строгой відповідності з
рекомендаціями є число визначеня для
нашого університету а також представники
з інших університетів це є всіічкиє
академія наук це
із кам'янець-подільського університету
Чернігівського тобто в нас різні дякую Я
знаю про це і Аналогічно Я так розумію
що і в Харківському університеті
педагогічному Аналогічно таккож
представники педагоги із різних е вищих
навчальних
закладів Почекайте я почув я почув
зараз от два
отих та заключення двох серйозних вчаних
рад А тепер хотів спитати от шановних
двох паній які от тут апелювали Скажіть
будь ласка ви фахівці в доктора наук
педагогіки та де ми вміємо читати у
в нас вміють читати 99% зараз в Україні
Дякую вам все я я відповідь почув свою
тощо я
хотів будь ласка
Михайло Станіслава Миколайовича
Станіслава ви ваша спецрада приймала
рішення з урахуванням усіх цих скар які
продчали Дякую за запитання Шановний
Михайло зарович коли ми приймали рішення
спеціалізованої ради по захисту Катерини
Михайлівни її роботи то всі зауваження
які були на той момент були враховані а
ось 10 червня коли ми вже розглядали то
нам переслали Міністерство освіти
сформовані зауваження і ми вже їх
обговорювали ми дисертацію не
обговорювали тому що Харківський
університет єсь от фахівці люди вони
обговорювали Я вважаю що це в цьому є
чистота не той хто за заи проводив сам
себе оцінює а люди які Тобто ми все
врахувалирківсько
університету
[музика]
даваразіки
слу Харківського педагогічного
університету імені
сковородина Світлана фимівна заступник
голови спеціалізованої вченої ради
правильно так будь ласка тільки Я
закликаю два слова Мені прикро що
сьогодні я почула стільки
ганебного в адресу педагогічної науки Я
підтримую те що люди які не знаю я сама
за фахом математик але
все-таки ну прикро що люди які фізика
математичний факультет там або філософія
вони без без яких критерії оцінюють
роботу я скажу
по-перше коли нам надіслали роботу дійс
дійсно Ми дуже хвилювались Бо все-таки
питання про плагіат - це дуже таке
важливе питання було призначено комісіюю
фахівці у нас були саме з цієї із
іноватики з педагогічної культури і до
речі Іонова яка доктор педнаук вона
кандидат фізико-математичних наук тобто
вони продивились на плагіат і було
дійсно виявлено Що плагіату в такому
вигляді як було сказано немає відсутн
воно є в оглядо частині і не плагіат а
все-таки запозичення ідей наукових і
положень наукових не має це гарантуємо
тому спеціалізована вчена рада має шість
членів
членівкореспондентів Академії педагічних
Наук вона зріла Це дійсно така в Рада
яка працює вже 25 років Вона має такий
термін і обсяг роботи і я Мені дуже було
ну соромно чути на адресу нашої ради І
на адресу там до речі є в письмі така
деталька що робота захищалась на
одноразовому захисті одноразовий захист
ви знаєте Ну я просто теж готувала дуже
багато слів щоб сказати але це теж Ну
така невірна невірна посилка бо рада
існує і Рада захищала вже дуже багато і
там є декілька докторських декілька
кандидатських дисертацій і ви чули
виступ Катерини Михайлівни Це дійсно
зріла людина і коли вона виступала у нас
на нашій раді Ми задавали дуже багато
питань Ми кожен ознайомився І до речі
якщо ви може побачити в справі є великий
такий талмут е висновку який робила
спеціалізована вчена рада Я підтримую
рішення е цієї ради не тільки тому що я
представник ради спеціалізованої з
Харкова
дякую
дякую будь ласка які в нас є пропозиції
що рішення
голосвати те
Шановні колеги погляньте у нас зараз
є рішення двох спеціалізованих вчених
рад яке є позитивни У нас є звернення
скаржників так само на ці рішення
спеціалізованих ченикрад Сьогодні ми
винесли на атестаційну колегію це
питання не по
процедурі тому що в принципі ми могли б
його не виносити але ми його винесли
тому що воно має великий публічний
розголос і для нас було важливо щоб всі
люди і ті які оскаржть
іті які просто читають з масових засобів
інформації інформацію якій схильні
довіряти щоб вони почули реальний Стан
справ тому ми винесли це публічно на
атестаційну колегію аби всі могли
ознайомитися з ситуацією Я вважаю що
Оскільки було дуже просторо висловлено
зауваження до дисертації Але ми не
зачитали висновки спеціалізованих вчених
того де теж дуже просторо надані зовсім
інші аргументи ці письмові висновки теж
можна побачити всюди е я
прошу зараз членів атестаційної колегії
е запропонувати які на вашу думку ми
можемо зараз рішення прийняти в цій
ситуації будь
ласка Я звик поступати наступним чином
якщо не знаєш як робити Роби по закону
що нам каже закон мон приймає рішення
про позбавлення виключно на підставі
рішень спеціалізованих чених наразі
спеціалізована вчена рада не вбачає
флагіату Я не вважаю дві ради дві ради
дві ради Я не вважаю се настільки
експертом щоб там їх переглядати рішення
вчиних спеціалізованих рад сидять
доктори роблятьсяце кандидати тобто люди
які мають відповідні вчинні заня Я
повністю довіряю рішенням спеціалізовано
вчини попоную в якості рішення колегії
взяти до відома рішення спеціалізовано
вче так
точноправи будь ласка є ще якісь
пропо Я також хочу сказати одну річ для
тих для тих заявників які звичайно
будуть незадоволені нашим рішенням і це
буде супроводжуватися знову якимись
публікаціями Я хочу попросити вас
переведіть ее
ваші
аргументи просто словесних непідстав ну
без безпідставних звинувачень в якісь
інституційні ее
злагоджені реально науковою експертизою
факти тому що наразі Ми не маємо що
розглядати окрім ваших особистих
заяв
Отже Шановні колеги приймаємо цю
інформацію і цей розгляд до
відома іншого
рішення в нормативно-правовому полі і на
основі тих аргументів які ми послухали
Сьогодні ми прийняти не
можемою